avec nous ce soir valérie fourneyron
ministre des sports de la jeunesse on
n'oublie pas l'éducation populaire et la
vie associative bonsoir bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous nous allons faire votre
connaissance au cours de cette émission
vos engagements passés et actuels
également votre passé de sportive volley
yeux ce sera avec perrine tarneaud avant
cela avec françoise chaptal notre
partenaire de l' agence france-presse
ce soir eh bien nous évoquons ce qui
ressemble à une trêve des confiseurs sur
le dossier du dopage centième tour de
france oblige sans doute ce n'est
qu'après l'arrivée sur les champs
elysées à la fin du mois donc que sera
dévoilé le très attendu rapport de la
commission d' enquête du sénat sur le
dopage dans tous les sports je précise
françois hollande s'est d'ailleurs rendu
samedi dernier sur la grande boucle
valérie fourneyron l'occasion d'un bain
de foule bagnères de bigorre est ce que
c'était un mirage pour lui sur sa
popularité
je crois que c'était important qu'ils
soient sur ce grand événement sportif
mondial c'est vraiment le tour de france
a fait rayonner notre pays s'est fait
partie de notre patrimoine
puis il est aussi allé à saint béat sur
voir l'ensemble des habitants qui
avaient été sinistrés par ces
inondations alors moins d'un français
sur quatre aujourd'hui se disent
satisfaits de son action à gauche les
mécontents sont même maintenant
majoritaire c'est comme chez les
champions il faut un mental en ce moment
pour diriger la france savait on n'a
jamais imaginé que sa lettre simple de
notre pays effectivement être très
endetté avec en plus situation
économique et sociale difficile
donc on savait que la première année
sera une période de redressement
aujourd'hui enfin des outils sont au
rendez vous le travail sur la
sécurisation de l'emploi à la fois à la
réflexion sur politique familiale
l'ensemble des engagements que nous
avons pris en matière d'enseignement de
sécurité de justice
le premier ministre annonce aujourd'hui
tout un plan investissements d'avenir à
la fois sur le secteur de la transition
énergétique sur le secteur essentiel des
transports de la mobilité mais aussi
l'économie numérique et enfin toute la
dimension santé recherche il y à là je
vais dire des perspectives indispensable
c'est vraiment dégagée dans notre budget
qui est un budget sérieux responsable
avec pour la première fois dépenses
d'état qui sont en diminution c'est la
première fois de l'histoire de la vème
république diminuera de 14 milliards
d'euros les dépenses de l'état en 2014
mais au service de nos priorités au
service de l'ensemble de ce programme
d'investissement et de ses priorités
donc en matière d'emploi d'éducation de
logement également de sécurité de
justice quand vous au ministère des
sports c'est donc ce bien l'austérité
vous le confirme et d'ailleurs votre
budget en baisse d'année en année ça a
commencé bien avant l'alternance
la dernière c'est un petit budget mais
aujourd'hui c'est un budget grillé c'est
un budget qui est sérieux qui est bras
de levier
parce que le sport a une place très
importante dans notre paysage national
et qui était pour moi essentiel qu'on
soit dans ce budget d'hier dans les
justes décisions
je prends un exemple sur le sport le
centre national de développement du
sport
j'ai souhaité le réorienter vers là où
il ya le plus grand nombre d' inégalité
d'accès au sport il y en a encore
beaucoup dans notre pays
alors ça crée des remous avec toute
l'organisation du sport dans notre pays
on en parlera un petit peu plus tard il
ya des obstacles qui se dressent sur
votre gros moteur travaille on travaille
ça revient avec la fédération et tout le
monde sait qu'aujourd'hui le score c'est
pas simplement l'état et le mouvement
sportif c'est aussi les collectivités
locales qui sont très présentes et dans
quelles ont envie de participer à cette
politique sportive devant garder votre
budget franchement vous avez des raisons
de vous plaindre
or vous ne faites pas alors vous ne
faites pas non je le fais parce que
d'abord je considère qu'on doit
participer à l'effort collectif
et puis aussi parce que j'ai la
possibilité de faire mes propres choix
il ya eu une année 2013 avec une
réduction importante du budget du sport
en 2014
on sera sur une mission qui est beaucoup
plus protégés est donc je pourrais
continuer à faire les choix
vous savez il ya par exemple dans le
monde du sport des fédérations sportives
qui pour lesquels le budget de l'état
est infime
d'autres pour lesquels il est essentiel
pour poursuivre tous les sports n'ont
pas les mêmes besoins d'argent n'est pas
équilibré dans le square jean reno sport
il n'y a pas chez moi c'est sûr j'ai
d'ailleurs trouvé des fédérations
sportives extrêmement responsable
bien consciente on avait cette nécessité
ensemble de servir l'ensemble du sport
français
bon alors vous êtes lancé delphine batho
je vous écoute et votre budget et puis
vous défendez la ligne générale du
gouvernement
c'est indispensable la solidarité du
gouvernement elle est essentielle et
bien dire derrière le budget nous nous
retrouvons tous mais dans un souci qui
est vraiment un souci de sérieux un
souci à la fois de courage mais
également de faire les justes décisions
et de dégager enfin des marges de
manoeuvre pour regarder l'avenir
c'est à la fois 2014 et puis c'est aussi
pouvoir regarder l'avenir avec ses
perspectives ses perspectives pour notre
jeunesse ses perspectives d
investissement d'avenir que nous lançons
l'ensemble de ces investissements par
exemple en termes de mobilité de
transport sont essentiels en termes de
soutien à l'emploi
c'est pour nous majeur les jeunes qui
sont loin de l'emploi avec l'ensemble
des dispositifs d'accompagnement
s'agisse des emplois d'avenir serait
j'ai des contrats de génération on est
loin des 100 milles 1 c'est l'objectif
de cette année les emplois d'amener à ce
que le sport contribue suffisamment et
bien atteindre cet objectif
absolument et ré fin du premier semestre
nous étions sur un tiers des 100 milles
ce qui génère était tout à fait
la perspective envisagée par le ministre
de l'emploi et du travail et le sport y
contribuer pourquoi parce que dans le
secteur du sport dans le secteur de la
jeunesse
nous avons la possibilité d'accompagner
des jeunes n'ont pas de qualification
jusqu'à un brevet professionnel jusqu'à
jeudi un vrai métier il y a dans le
secteur du sport dans le secteur des
rythmes périscolaire beaucoup de
nouvelles activités la possibilité dans
nos clubs aussi d'accompagner plus
d'enfants en situation de handicap de
porter la politique qui est une de mes
priorités autour du sport santé les
clubs peuvent s'ouvrir à toutes les
nouvelles politiques du coup il ya de
l'emploi on écoute un discours très
positif
vous êtes heureuse
dans votre angle furent budgétaire vous
dites qu'il vous permet néanmoins de
faire des choix est-ce que la démission
contrainte de des films et toi et
changer quelque chose à la vie des
ministres aujourd'hui on est obligé de
positiver c'est dans un gouvernement la
nécessité d'avoir c'est en ces temps je
veux dire de débat on les a au moment
des arbitrages budgétaires on les a et
puis une fois je veux dire qu'on a
l'arbitrage qui a été rendu il ya cette
solidarité indispensable le gouvernement
à dire ah je vais dire un cap qui est
claire nous voulons et c'était vraiment
l'essentiel de ce début de mandat
redresser notre pays
j'insiste parce que sur 7 5 dernières
années il y avait eu quand même une
explosion de l'endettement de la france
et vous savez faut le dire mais les
sportifs au moment du budget on dit mais
vous savez quand on augmente la dette
c'est pas plus d'argent pour le sport
c'est plus d'argent pour l'intérêt de la
dette
donc aujourd'hui on a absolument besoin
de redresser les comptes publics
et pour la première fois et bien le
train de vie de l'état va diminuer c'est
une bonne chose
vous avez des concertations heureuse
avec le premier parce qu'il a encore sa
méthode a été critiquée je vais pas
toujours citer l'ancien ministre de
l'écologie mme enfin estimé qu'il y
avait des décisions qui tombait comme sa
décision couperet d'ailleurs on a un
mode de fonctionnement avec matignon
avec l'équipe du premier ministre qui
nous permet de conduire nos arbitrages
et puis d'aller défendre nos positions
parce que c'est essentiel que nous
puissions défendre nos positions et puis
une fois une fois qu'elles sont arbitrés
la solidarité elle est nécessaire sinon
on ne peut pas conduire une politique
globale alors vous l'avez rappelé il ya
des fédérations qui ont beaucoup
d'argent
contrairement au ministère des sports
est ce que c'est vrai que votre ethnie
dépendant fait moins de l' enveloppe
budgétaire que vous allez matignon que
des paris en ligne
bien des droits sportifs alors il ya une
enveloppe effectivement du programme
sport d'environ 230 millions d'euros est
pris à le centre national de
développement du sport dont les rousses
halifax dont les recettes sont
effectivement les droits télé
effectivement les paris en ligne
et puis l'ensemble des jeux de la
française des jeux est donc cette
enveloppe
elle est de 270 millions d'euros dont un
peu supérieurs sont réels problèmes
c'est comme quand on est arrivé en
juillet 2012
j'ai fait le compte 500 millions d'euros
étaient engagés sur cette enveloppe pour
un budget de 170 millions d'euros sur
l'exercice 2012 100 millions de dépenses
de plus que de recettes donc j'ai fait
voter
c'était en novembre dernier un plan de
redressement de ce centre national de
développement du sport parce que même
manière il fallait absolument qu'on ne
l'emmène pas définitivement dans le mur
et qu'on puisse se donner des
perspectives perspective d'ailleurs
elles ont été clairement aussi relevés
par la cour des comptes qui dans son
rapport de cet été dit l'état n'a pas
été au rendez vous pour diminuer les
inégalités d'accès aux sports est donc
pour nous c'est à la fois le plan de
redressement qu'il faut conduire est à
la fois je veux dire être plus au
rendez-vous pour l'état de cette ces
inégalités qui existent malheureusement
de façon encore trop importantes dans
certains territoires ruraux dans
certains quartiers populaires pour
certains publics nous accabler mon
prédécesseur
est ce que le retour à peine masqué d'un
nicolas sarkozy vous inquiète on vous
fait peur je veux pas accabler mes
prédécesseurs sur le centre national de
développement du sport vraiment il ya eu
une attitude qui a été pour moi
irresponsable d'engager tant de moyens
et de ne pas avoir les recettes en face
avec nicolas rey campagne de nicolas
sarkozy vers une sincérité des comptes
dans tous les cas nicolas sarkozy et va
dire ses comptes
effectivement n'ont pas été validés par
le conseil constitutionnel
j'imagine qu'ils savaient pas dire les
risques qu'ils prenaient par rapport à
l'ensemble de ses dépenses de campagne
alors aujourd'hui son retour est ce qui
nous inquiète c'est je crois qu'il est
assez responsable de la situation dans
laquelle se retrouve son parti et donc
me semble qu'en ce sens il doit être au
moment où son parti
difficulté françois hollande est proche
on peut le dire avait mis la jeunesse au
coeur de sa campagne
concrètement c'est donc une promesse qui
vous lit et de quelle façon
aujourd'hui la jeunesse ça effectivement
dans cette belle feuille de route de se
dire qu'en 2017 elles doivent vivre
mieux qu'en 2012 et pour nous ça a été
un véritable défi que nous avons voulu
relever par simplement le ministère de
la jeunesse
mais 24 ministres qui ont travaillé
depuis plusieurs mois pour aboutir à une
feuille de route collective qui permet
non pas la mesure jeunes parce que je
veux dire on ne va pas améliorer la
situation des jeunes avec une mesure
mais au contraire accompagner tous les
jeunes de notre pays en les accompagnant
dans leur parcours d'autonomie
comment est ce que finalement on passe
de l'école jusqu'à son insertion
professionnelle
comment est-ce qu'on passe de sa famille
d'origine à sa famille choisie il ya des
moments dans ce parcours d'autonomie
il faut pouvoir être bien orienté il
faut moment donné pouvoir accéder au
logement accéder à la santé pouvoir
jeudi retrouvez l'ensemble de ses outils
publics qui permettent de construire son
propre parcours
vous avez des jeunes qui ont envie de
créer leur entreprise pendant est-ce
qu'elles accèdent à la bpi
j'en ai rencontré récemment qu'ils
étaient partis sur un grand colloque on
les a envoyés avec l'office
franco-québécois de la jeunesse vous en
avez d'autres qui sont sur la création
de l'entreprise dans l'économie sociale
et solidaire
on a voulu augmenter les moyens dans
l'engagement des jeunes théo de
l'engagement volontaire des jeunes
autour du service civique
mais également on a souhaité dans la loi
que va porter cécile duflot il ya un des
éléments majeurs pour la construction de
l'autonomie des jeunes c'est leur accès
à leur logement
or 80% aujourd'hui des locataires dans
notre pays ont moins de 30 ans et donc
quand vous travaillez sur une garantie
locative
quand vous travaillez sur réglementer un
peu mieux les meublés ou ce qu'on
appelle les marchands de listes et bien
vous travaillez pour améliorer l'accès à
l'autonomie des jeunes et à leur
logement
donc c'est mal ou pas je veux dire c'est
toute la construction d'une priorité
jeunesse qui parle à tous les jeunes
avec un dernier élément si je veux
rajouter parce que c'est pour moi
essentiel c'est pas une politique est
construite simplement pour les jeunes
elle est construite avec les jeunes et
moi j'ai voulu que les jeunes soient en
permanence
ans a travaillé avec cette feuille de
route et donc nous avons ensemble
c'est-à-dire fait en sorte que le forum
français de la jeunesse l'ensemble les
collectifs de jeunesse puisse échanger
avec les différents ministères et vous
aurez dès la fin de l'année parce que la
circulaire est parti dans les conseils
économiques et sociaux environnementaux
dans chacune des régions de france
vous aurez enfin une place pour les
jeunes il faut que les jeunes soient
dans toutes nos instances qui
construisent les politiques publiques
c'est essentiel faut le faire avec
allez on va abandonner un temps la
jeunesse n'a pas totalement en abordant
d'autres dossiers sportifs sunu libyen
avec hansen chaptal notre concert de la
sp donc être là ce soir et pour
introduire cette deuxième séquence c'est
bien les difficultés de chaque ministre
des sports affronter le fléau du dopage
fabrice qu'une heure jeudi tous les
jours je suis propre
je n'ai aucun doute et je ne suis pas
inquiet je pourrais être testé tous les
jours c'était le 3 juillet dernier à
paris
le roi du sprint usain bolt tentait de
rassurer les sceptiques mais derrière le
masque toujours des questions
même discours volontariste sur le tour
les coureurs sont des piles électriques
qui marcherait à l'eau claire
en attendant les ministres des sports
marche depuis toujours sur des oeufs
jean françois lamour l'un de ces
empêcheurs de se doper au bidon raconte
un casse tête
il ya des lobbys évident des lobbys des
fédérations internationales et des de
certains états qui considère que c'est
un luth accessoires des fédérations
aussi qui estime que le spectacle entre
guillemets sportif peut pâtir d'une
lutte antidopage affirmé donc c'est tout
cela qu'il faut non seulement apaisé
mais m à peu près autour de la table et
ça demande beaucoup de temps devant la
commission d' enquête du sénat david
douillet n'a pas raconter autre chose
l'histoire d'une certaine solitude du
ministre des sports face au dopage
évidemment ministre tout seul vous ne
pouvez rien bien sûr le mouvement
sportif le milieu sportif les
fédérations le comité nation et un pic
le comité international
on doit prendre ses responsabilités leur
responsabilité ainsi que ceux qui
organisent les compétitions
tout le monde joue le jeu solo il faut
que tout le monde non j'ai pas dit que
tous les jouets jeux il faut que tout le
monde joue pour gagner la partie
et ce serait loin d'être le cas c'est du
moins le constat que fait le docteur
jean pierre de mondenard
pour une raison simple difficile d'être
juge et partie
la lutte antidopage est entre les mains
de dans l'entreprise du spectacle donc
c'est pas possible il faut que la lutte
antidopage sortent des fédérations tant
qu'elles sont dans le monde du sport et
il y aura pas de réussite
la commission d' enquête du sénat devait
rendre son rapport et les noms des dopés
du tour 98 temps plein grande messe du
vélo elle attendra finalement trois
jours et que la caravane passe les
chiens eux n'ont pas fini d'aboyer vos
questions oui alors madame fourneyron
justement ce rapport qu'ont évoqués dans
le reportage pourquoi avoir demandé au
sénateur est ce que ces conclusions soit
reportée à l'après tour est ce que c'est
pour ne pas gâcher la fête est ce que
elles seront moins douloureuses après le
tour que pendant ce sont les sénateurs
qui ont décidé de leur calendrier qui
ont décidé de reporter effectivement
leur calendrier initial tran que de
demander des pressions joueurs alors moi
j'ai rencontré au moment du départ du
tour de france
non j'ai rencontré au moment du départ
du tour de france
l'ensemble des coureurs qui sont venus
effectivement exprimé un peu leur
ras-le-bol de se dire cette histoire de
la commission denquête et des procès
verbaux il l'a de 98 nous nous essayons
d'avancer tout n'est pas forcément
facile nous essayons d'avancer mais nous
souhaitons que génère l'ensemble de
cette histoire ancienne période peut
dire noir du tour de france ne ne
sortent pas au moment je vais dire de
dutourd 2013 mais j'adore c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment les sénateurs qui en ont
décidé seul et j'avais bien précisé
d'ailleurs aux coureurs
je veux dire qu'elles n'étaient pas
faire dans mon pouvoir de modifier leur
calendrier parce qu'il y avait une chose
aussi qui a sans doute pesé c'est qu'on
a trop lié ce rapport comme vous
l'évoquiez tout à l'heure uniquement au
tour de france est uniquement au
cyclisme avec le tour de france est pas
simplement le dopage le dopage c'est pas
simplement que le tour de france et donc
on avait besoin c'est à dire qu'il y ait
aussi peut-être de prendre un petit peu
de recul par rapport à uniquement
ciblées il stigmatise élevé mais les
coureurs et les autres sportifs donc ont
quand même reproché à la commission de
déterrer les morts
quelle quelle est leur but en publiant
cette liste finalement qui a 15 ans le
temps a changé le cyclisme a changé la
période à changer quel est le but des
sénateurs et ça faut leur demander
mais moi ce qui me semble important
aujourd'hui c'est de se dire que tout ce
qui doit nous faire progresser sur la
lutte contre le dopage doit être mis sur
la table il y a il faut qu'il y ait
aucune impunité pour le dopage
il faut arrêter de dire que soit ils
sont tous dopés soi que les contrôles
soient inefficaces soient qu'il faut
jamais parler du dopage parce que sa
période du tour de france non on va dire
il faut absolument que l'on puisse en
permanence progressé à l'évidence il ya
des améliorations qui ont été apportées
on voit plus de la moitié des équipes
aujourd'hui sont derrière le mpcc le
mouvement pour un cyclisme crédible
on voit aujourd'hui qu'il y a je veux
dire des performances qui ne sont pas
celles qu'on voyait dans ces périodes là
bas comme le scénario sportif de ces
derniers jours qu est-ce qui est qu'est
ce qui vous inspire est ce qui vous
rappelle pas une période au début des
années 2
mais quand l'équipe d'armstrong dominé
mais il faut pas non plus penser à dire
il n'ya pas d'angélisme dans ma voix il
faut pas non plus penser que l'ensemble
du dopage est derrière le peloton donc
requis à il faut à la fois non
stigmatisés chacune des performances et
je vais pas me transformer en jugeant
n'ayant aucune je veux dire preuve ni à
charge ni à décharge
mais il faut aussi se rendre compte que
aujourd'hui même les yeux dans les yeux
dire la vérité ne lève pas de tout
soupçon et que nous avons besoin de
continuer et pour continuer moi c'est un
peu aussi le message que je porte
il faut absolument lever l'omerta mais
il faut aussi que le peloton que
l'ensemble de ces acteurs nous aide
il faut aussi que l'ensemble de ces
acteurs nous n il y a encore dans des
environnements j'ai dit il ya encore des
gens qui ont été condamnés
il y a on a besoin de lever l'omerta et
c'est ça le plus important
la chasse à la sorcière elle n'est pas
intéressante et importante aujourd'hui
vous avez des suspicions un an quand on
parle de crise prendre par exemple
s'interroger on peut s'interroger oui on
peut s'interroger monsanto rose toujours
des cas des performances dans le sport
non stigmatisation nos aveuglements
vraiment c'est ça c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui j'avais vraiment on a besoin
on ne va pas juger sans preuve toute
façon on le voit bien les tricheurs à
jour ou l'autre ils sont rattrapés et
les autres et les autres la direction
panthéon
donc au bout d'un moment au bout d'un
moment on a absolument besoin de
continuer à progresser je crois que et
on ne le fera pas c'est vraiment ça on
ne le fera pas sans les acteurs
eux-mêmes cette année justement en tant
que ministre des sports du pays
organisateur du tour de france en tant
que membres européens de l'ama au comité
exécutif de l'ama est ce que vous avez
fait en sorte que les contrôles sur ce
tour 2013 soit peut-être plus crédible
plus performant que les autres années
oui pour la première fois celle agence
française de lutte contre le dopage qui
dans les contrôles avant le tour pendant
le tour décide de l'ensemble de ce
qu'elle fait je veux dire de ciblage de
ces contrôles
elle a à disposition la géolocalisation
du cycliste la disposition leur
passeport biologique
c'est à dire qu'il y a enfin une
indépendance avec l'organisateur l'union
cycliste internationale il ya enfin
cette indépendance
j'avais fait un peu le lien
effectivement je vais dire j'ai mis un
peu de poids à ce que cette convention
puisse être enfin signé entre l'union
cycliste internationale et l'agencé
française de lutte contre le dopage et
j'ai fait une deuxième chose à dire que
tu as une deuxième chose pendant ce tour
où il ya eu un travail de coordination
avec un décret signé par le premier
ministre un travail de coordination
entre le ministère de la justice le
ministère de l'économie qui étreint qui
est responsable des douanes
et puis venir l'ensemble du ministère de
l'intérieur pour police gendarmerie
alors qu'on puisse partager un peu mieux
les informations ce qui est intéressant
c'est pas cibler le coureur c'est de
voir tout le trafic qui peut exister
autour c'est ça qui doit nous permettre
de progresser puis je n'oublie pas comme
médecin de protéger la santé aussi parce
que moi je trouve c'est un véritable
drame de voir ces sportifs qui sont de
véritables cobayes humains parce que ce
sont parfois des molécules de l'air qui
sont même pas mise sur le marché qui
sont aujourd'hui on ne connaît même pas
les effets secondaires
une question quand même parce qu'il n'y
a pas de victoire d'étape française
jusqu'à dans ce tour est ce que c'est
une bonne nouvelle a fallu dire ce que
ça a un sens en matière de dopage
l'autre on france n'est pas fini le
premier français est 14e c'est vrai
c'est vrai qu'on aimerait c'est vrai
vérifications en matière de dopage
je crois qu'aujourd'hui il faut pas tout
ramener au dopage le tour de france ce
n'est pas que le dopage
le président de la république et à
bagnères de bigorre a dit je veux croire
que ce tour est propre vous voulez
croire vous aussi que ce tout en
particulier le tour 2013 bien sûr vous
voulez quoi redresse
on progresse mais il faut que le peloton
l'ensemble de cet environnement nous
aide nous avaient dynamité
voilà d'accord si vous permettez
d'autres sujets sportifs dans plus que
vous inspire le scénario de pré saison
de ligue 1 de foot avec le grand mercato
entre le grand duel du mercato entre
monaco et le paris saint germain est ce
qu'on va vers une saison
un championnat à deux vitesses pour la
saison prochaine avec monaco et le psg
qui qui feront un duel entre eux et puis
le reste du peloton derrière les autres
clubs de ligue 1 et je me rends la
troisième place le sport professionnel
c'est pas que de l'argent mais c'est de
l'argent quand même mais c'est vrai
aussi que les résultats les résultats
parfois donne tort au budget on l'a vu
cette année avec qui a gagné le
championnat de proa de basket
c'est nanterre un des plus petits
budgets l'année dernière c'était
montpellier qui avait gagné le
championnat de france de ligue 1 donc
c'est vrai qu'il ya aujourd'hui génère
des budgets qui sont avec des
proportions qui vont du simple au
quadruple à fasse un 4 x 6 et cetera
donc il faut pas non plus diaboliser les
investisseurs étrangers
il faut se dire que c'est pas
inintéressant pour notre football
d'avoir un football est un championnat
attractif mais cette impression globale
aujourd'hui du football professionnel
une véritable dérégulation financière
parfois d'une véritable bulle
spéculative doit tous nous interroger je
sais que les temps mais aussi le
mouvement sportif le mouvement du
football comme on est les collectivités
locales qui investissent dans leurs
équipements et biens sont
particulièrement attentives sollicités
nous commençons à travailler beaucoup de
rapports sur le fair play financier un
travail mené à l'uefa avec michel
platini la commission européenne qui
travaille sur les transferts on a vu
tout ce qui s'est passé ces dernières
années et continue des salaires qu'on
explose et des transferts cpt ont
explosé des droits télés etc ont plutôt
eu tendance à baisser chuté parfois oui
il ya des salaires qui sont à
aujourd'hui qui choque les français ya
14 % des français qui vivent sous le
seuil de pauvreté
donc on a aujourd'hui jungle
des salaires qui sont particulièrement
qui particulièrement choquant mais il
faut par ailleurs ce simplement
stigmatisé cet élément pour moi ça doit
être un moment où l'ensemble du football
doit réfléchir à cette régulation on a
des clubs en espagne en italie au
portugal où les joueurs sont plus payés
on a aujourd'hui je venais des
situations qui interroge tout le monde
assez souvent dans vos discours
l'abolition du système des transferts
notamment des indemnités de transfert
qui elle aussi comme les salaires
atteignent des sommes délirantes
est ce que vous y croyez ce que c'est
réaliste est ce que c'est un effet
d'annoncé ou est ce qu'on peut vraiment
arriver à une vraie suppression de ces
indemnités
je pense qu'on y arrivera pourquoi on y
arrivera parce qu'aujourd'hui à la fois
le syndicat des joueurs professionnels
internationale est favorable la
commission européenne
effectivement y est également est en
train de travailler sur ce sujet donc on
voit bien qu'on a un sujet à la fois
français mais que ce sujet il est
beaucoup plus large et que tant qu'on
n'aura pas avancé avec l'europe autour
d'une direction nationale de contrôle et
de gestion européennes
nous on est plutôt vertueux dans ce
modèle même si les déficits de nos clubs
professionnels se sont aggravées donc on
a besoin de cette régulation européenne
sans doute aboutir un jour à un
plafonnement des salaires à ce que les
transferts disparaissent ou aussi que à
l'occasion de ces transferts on a tout
de même beaucoup d'interrogations sur
l'origine un certain nombre de moyens
financiers sur les rôles joués par les
agents de joueurs des agents qui parfois
gens dire sont multiples dans une
transaction
donc tout cela ne mérite à l'évidence
plus de transparence
et puis fait vivre un espèce de
d'environnement autour d'une spéculation
autour du football et je pense que ça
s'est pas fait tout ça comme comme le
dopage d'ailleurs sera au centre de
votre loi de programmation qu'elle
prévue pour la rentrée
absolument je trouve que je n'ai pas
souhaité me précipiter pour faire une
loi va lire dès la première année de mes
responsabilités souhaité prendre le
temps parce que dans cette loi on doit
travailler à la fois sur l' équilibre
sport et argent sport professionnel
l'ensemble de ces mécanismes de
régulation on doit travailler aussi sur
c'est quoi un service public
du sport pourquoi si encore beaucoup
d'inégalités l'accès au sport c'est quoi
un outil éducatif de cohésion sociale
autour du sport on a tous ces enjeux à
partager avec le mouvement sportif avec
les collectivités locales est
aujourd'hui pense que tous les acteurs
ont bien conscience qu'un la loi 84 qui
fait encore référence c'était une loi où
il y avait avant tout deux partenaires
mouvement sportif et a aujourd'hui nous
sommes beaucoup plus nombreux le sujet
est complètement différent l'éthique
doit être aussi respecter on vient de le
voir avec le débat sur le dopage
alors même si j'ai encore pour l'euro
les stades de leur all wheel est du
sport du de l'état au sport
professionnel ça fait c'est aussi un
parallèle des stades de l'euro vous êtes
auditionné demain l'assemblée nationale
sur ce sujet je crois est ce que vous
trouvez que l'état dépense trop pour le
sport professionnel des dépenses mal
pour le sport m'ont donné entrons au prg
au touquet la solidarité entre le sport
professionnel et sport amateur n'est pas
au rendez vous de ce qu on pourrait
souhaiter c'est vrai que sur les stades
de l'euro il y avait eu donc pris sur le
centre national de développement du
sport c'est à dire sur le sport pour
tous a été pris à dire 160 millions
d'euros alors qu' avec 120 de recettes
pour les stades de l'euro 2016 on
tiendra nos engagements mais on sent
bien que ce modèle global il est un peu
à bout de souffle cette solidarité elle
s'exerce pas de façon satisfaisante
à nous de trouver les nouvelles
modalités mais j'insiste parce que tout
le monde est persuadé aujourd'hui y
compris le milieu du football
professionnel la fédération française de
football les entraîneurs comme les
joueurs que nous avons besoin de trouver
des modèles de régulation qu'ils soient
plus satisfaisant dernière question est
ce que vous êtes
est ce que vous êtes favorable à ce que
paris la france mais paris a priori soit
candidate à la l organisation des jeux
en 2024 attendons septembre puisqu'en
septembre on saura qui organise les jeux
de 2020 et en fonction si c'est madrid
tokyo istanbul
il y aura où il n'y aura pas un jeu
c'est à dire à un créneau pour un pour
un continent ce jeu là vous n'êtes donc
pas favorable à la candidature à tout
prix comme le
le sont certains membres du mouvement
sportif il faut aujourd'hui je pense que
mouvement sportif est beaucoup plus
prudent que ça parce qu'après quatre
certes échec presque après quatre échecs
successifs beaucoup d'argent beaucoup
d'argent on n'a plus le droit d'échouer
et donc c'est pour ça que moi j'ai
souhaité réorganiser vraiment le comité
français du sport à l'international pour
qu'on puisse aller à une candidature
quand on sera prêt quand on sera dans
les conditions de la gagne et ça coûte
trop cher d'y aller et de perdre donc
aujourd'hui faut être très prudent et me
dire merci françois et chaptal ce soir
inferno de public sénat arrive
maintenant madame la ministre
juste après ces quelques éléments
biographiques rassurez-vous parfois un
peu à géographique
parmi les personnes qu'on a rencontrés
sur vont pour vous réunis par marie
vraiment tous ceux qui la connaissent
sont unanimes
valérie fourneyron a du tempérament et
l'exercice du pouvoir n'a visiblement
pas d'effet sur cette femme d'un mètre
65 mais qui chose du 41 pour garder les
pieds sur terre comme elle aime à dire
je trouve que voilà c'est la même
personne que j'ai en face de moi ce côté
très très direct très très clair voilà
avec une belle tension est donc je
dirais que la fonction n'a pas changé la
femme la fonction n'a pas changé la
femme il faut dire qu'elle a de
l'expérience en politique elle accumule
les mandats depuis plusieurs années
maire de rouen et député de seine
maritime
c'est donc finalement assez
naturellement qu'elle décroche le
ministère des sports d'une très longue
histoire qui a commencé avant qu'elle ne
devienne député a fortiori ministre le
sport c'est sa seconde nature c'est sa
vie c'est son choix de vie le sport
valérie fourneyron koné et plus
particulièrement le volley-ball qu'elle
pratique adolescente en équipe de france
cadettes
si ensuite elle quitte le terrain elle
n'est jamais bien loin des athlètes
puisque désormais elle les soigne et
c'est en tant que médecin du sport
qu'elle collabore à la nouvelle
législation sur le dopage en 1999 une
autre femme marie george buffet est
alors ministre
je pense que
valérie est une femme de rigueur qui
portent certaine vision du sport que je
partage d'agir et sport porteur de
règles d'éthique c'est pas quelqu'un qui
cherche à faire parler d'elle de façon
superficielle briller de façon
superficielle discrète trop discrète
valérie fourneyron ceux qui la protège
et lui évite sans doute des couacs
voilà on a entendu volleyeuses de haut
niveau médecin du sport le sport c'est
votre seconde nature a dit patrick
bloche c'est vrai vous avez vraiment
pour le sport de moins en moins en terme
de pratiquants mais c'est vrai que je
suis tombé dedans petit en famille et
voilà donc j'ai découvert le sport avec
mon père sur le terrain de football du
football club de rouen est aussi le
premier club du président de la
république et puis ensuite à l'école
j'ai trouvé j'ai découvert le volley
ball et où et pour c'est vrai que
c'était important et au moment de
l'orientation professionnelle j'ai un
peu hésité entre rester allait vraiment
sur l'encadrement sportif ou la médecine
mais en première année de médecine
c'était un peu inattendu dans l'amphi
qu'il savait déjà que je voulais faire
médecine du score en première année de
médecine donc vraiment j'ai quelque
chose que j'ai construit et semblait
important de pouvoir rester dans ce
milieu et puis d'exercer une profession
j'essayais de garder le plus longtemps
possible y compris quand j'ai eu des
responsabilités politiques
j'avais vraiment besoin je crois de
garder un pied avec mon équilibre
professionnel
bon depuis 2004 c'est plus possible en
voulant voulait voulons vous si on ne
met la serpillière cd vous est il prêt à
plonger sur chacune des ballets ce camp
politique et où on se retrouve comme ça
à fond sur chaque dossier aussi j'aime
j'aime pas faire les choses à moitié
droite effectivement c'est la
serpillière fallait pas qu'il va
longtemps que partagent ce n'est pas
très grande quand même vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure je voulais vole donc
voilà je défendrai beaucoup époque les
libéraux qui est aujourd'hui existe au
volley-ball n'existait pas quand je
jouais et donc
c'est vrai que j'aime bien me battre sur
surtout les défis qu'on confie vous
n'êtes pas superficiel dit toujours dans
ce même mois au portage marie george
buffet sauf que l'un politique impose
aussi parfois de se faire connaître et
connaître par des par des coups d'éclat
ça c'est pas votre nature non c'est pas
ma nature je politique n'a pas changé
en tout cas je cherche pas peut-être
effectivement le cookie la mesure où son
existence est vrai sur la scène
politique et la scène médiatique
mais pas de quoi votre nature c'est pas
ma nature et je pense pas que la
politique inverse soit motivation pour
la changer parce que vous êtes déjà dans
le coup d'après ah non non je sais pas
dans le magazine roselyne bachelot dit
que vous êtes un peu sous caste et dans
un gouvernement elle a d'autres
ambitions pour vous parie beaucoup de la
santé elle voit le ministre de la santé
et celle et nos responsabilités
aujourd'hui qui est très large parce que
contrairement à ce qu'on peut penser
quand vous ajoutez le sport la jeunesse
à l'éducation populaire et la vie
associative est un périmètre une
responsabilité très importante et je
suis absolument ravi de la cohérence de
l'ensemble de ce ministère j'ai peu de
temps à moi est donc aujourd'hui je suis
effectivement à fond sur cette
responsabilité je voulais qu'on parle un
petit peu de féminisme est justement au
sein du gouvernement en ce moment on
assiste est un espèce de bateaux bashing
en ce moment de filippetti bashing est
ce que ça veut dire qu'il ya une espèce
de syndrome jupe est absolument pas je
trouve que les femmes au sein de ce
gouvernement nous nous avons
effectivement les unes et les autres
enfin notre personnalité et la
possibilité d'avoir des débats et des
échanges donc lui de l'equilibre de ceux
de ce gouvernement je trouve
particulièrement judicieux et grâce à la
parité vous pensez c'est un équipement
très intéressant qu'est ce que voulait
dire non mais sa personnalité pendant
effectivement de gens je crois que
aujourd'hui et on a là des femmes au
gouvernement qui on dirait vraiment des
personnalités qui permettent à ce qu'il
y ait de la qualité collective donc je
m'en réjouis mais quand même par ap
autour du limogeage de delphine batho on
a pu parler de deux poids deux mesures
est ce que vous pensez que comme
certains ont pu le dire c'est une
décision machiste alors pas du tout je
crois que la 10ème minute notamment
qu'il est chaud la décision est
parfaitement clair et quand la politique
que vous soyez élu local
ça y est parlementaire qui se fait dans
un gouvernement vous connaissez une
règle c'est celle du budget et donc la
solidarité elle s'exprime à tous ces
niveaux
et donc voilà donc je crois que c'était
extrêmement extrêmement simple et puis
rien à voir avec le sexe ministre en
question
d'autant que madame bateau n'a pas de
force fin n'a pas de ne représente pas
une force politique en elle-même contre
contrairement par exemple arnaud
montebourg vous même quel est votre
poids politique est ce qui le départ de
votre lien particulier avec françois
hollande exclusivement de ce lien là je
me pose pas la question tous les jours
de mon poids politique j'essaie de
conduire à dire parfois on le dit pas
assez en avant ou parfois bien mais
j'essaie de conduire mieux possible
l'ensemble des dossiers qui me sont
confiées et sans avoir ce souci en
permanence d'augmenter mon poids
politique
on va dire que ça compte dans certains
arbitrages notamment qu'on vous êtes
contestez vous est un arbitrage en votre
faveur ou défaveur le bing attend une
fédération sportive par exemple je
voulais des filles a pas que le travail
qui compte malgré tout je rêvais
j'essaye toujours l'air de pouvoir
défendre ce que je crois juste mais
alors quand je défonce les tendances
aller jusqu'au bout et je
je lâche par voilà est-ce que le sport
ça reste un univers très mat chose ça
reste un univers très macho surtout dans
l'ensemble de ces organisations
dirigeantes
on a aujourd'hui une seule femme
présidente fédération là une seule
présidente de fédération olympique des
scream
on a quatre femmes présentes fédérations
au total on a aujourd'hui chez nommé
deux femmes directrice technique
nationale avait pas j'en ai nommé 2-1 de
remplacer les directeurs d'établissement
dénomination paritaire mais on sent bien
qu'on a vraiment dans cet univers
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup d'hommes et
que la place des femmes d'aujourd'hui
minoritaires et qu' il faut absolument
que l'on agisse sur tous les plans à la
fois du nombre de licenciées féminines
d'accompagner les femmes à être
candidate pour des postes à
responsabilités mais aussi derrière
comme ça va être dans dans la loi de
najat vallaud belkacem qu'on aille
jusqu'à la parité dans les instances
dirigeantes alors en fonction des
disciplines
parce que je n'ai pas pouvoir imposer la
parité demain dans une discipline où les
femmes sont très minoritaires en termes
de pratiquantes
mais il faut qu'on aille vers 6h ce
chemin de la parité aussi dans le milieu
du sport et dans le milieu du sport dont
aussi parfois des journalistes sportifs
qui sont assez critiques envers les
femmes sportives notamment notamment
encore la semaine dernière à wimbledon
et commentateur alain journaliste
sportif de la bbc qui a critiqué le
physique de marion bartoli
vous avez entendu ces commentaires il a
réagi inqualifiable inacceptable en
liant bartoli est une formidable
championne et aujourd'hui je crois
qu'elle a traité ses propos par la
dérision elle a bien eu raison
mais quand même est-ce qu'il faudrait
sanctionner ce genre de commentaire
aujourd'hui l'ensemble des
discriminations et peuvent être
sanctionnés dans tous les cas chez nous
il ya des sanctions sur tout ce qui
concerne les discriminations et parce
que c'est indispensable qu'il y ait une
éthique dans toutes les professions elle
celle de journaliste en l'occurrence on
a dit qu'il y avait peu de femmes un
président de fédération et aussi des
hommes qui restent très longtemps en
place alors il ya certains de vos
prédécesseurs qui ont voulu l'imiter
nombre de mandats
à la tête d'une fédération est ce que ça
aussi c'est dans les cartons un nouveau
projet tout est dans le gansu d'accord
notamment quand il a été aux sports
s'est cassé les dents sur ce projet là
dans le conseil national du sport j'ai
installé cette semaine dont un des
enjeux justement et de revoir la
gouvernance du sport les équilibres
entre l'état le mouvement sportif les
collectivités et bien dans ces enjeux il
y à la gouvernance des fédérations ou
dernier rapport au parlement les députés
étaient sur la gouvernance des
fédérations et donc on a besoin de
travailler avec eux on va pas le faire
je veux dire contre elle mais à
l'évidence on a besoin de renouvellement
à la tête finir de l'ensemble du
mouvement sportif comment y arriver
plus de femmes plus de jeunes on
évoquait tout à l'heure la nécessité de
mettre dans les conseils économiques et
sociaux plus de jeunes dans toutes les
infos ouverte et aux barons des
fédérations sportives
oui il ya des barreaux mais il ya aussi
un certain nombre de présidentes et
présidents de fédérations qui ont ouvert
leurs portes et qui aujourd'hui sont
bien conscientes que ils ne peuvent pas
rester dans la situation actuelle sur le
twitter beaucoup téléspectateurs de
public sénat nous ont interpellés sur la
formule 1 à quand un retour de la
formule 1 sur un circuit français chien
la formule 1 mais la coupe en sait
d'ailleurs que que j'aimais pas
automobile la formule
j'aime ça j'aime ça et quand je suis
l'inventeur de la formule 1 en france
oui mais pas dans n'importe quelle
condition et l'eau quand je suis arrivé
il y avait deux dossiers le castellet et
magny cours et moi je dis simplement une
chose quand les conditions techniques et
financières seront remplies pourquoi pas
or la fédération française du sport
automobile qui examinait ses dossiers et
ben may très clairement apporté comme
conclusion que les conditions
financières étaient absolument pas
remplies pourquoi parce que le coût
d'achat du plateau c'est à dire de la
compétition à l'organisateur est
extrêmement élevée derrière vous pouvez
pas faire beaucoup de recettes parce
qu'en plus il a tous les droits
commerciaux qui sont autour de
l'organisation de cette compétition dont
il ya beaucoup de coups et puis il n'y a
pas beaucoup de possibilités de faire
des recettes
c'est une compétition qui s'achète en
droit anglais donc à un moment donné en
tous les cas l'argent public mais même
l'argent je vais dire des territoires et
de l'ensemble des organisateurs ne peut
pas être là pour acheter les chats dire
à en droit anglais une compétition et
puis surtout
pour essayer de boucher un trou leur
pack grand prix de france c'est en tous
les cas
tant que ces conditions financières sont
pas remplies le contribuable va tout de
même pas être je veux dire celui rapaces
celui où coin pourquoi il doit y avoir
des partenaires si j'ai tellement bien
huilée sur le plan commercial il peut y
avoir des partenaires qui ont envie des
partenaires privés qui ont envie c'est à
dire d'avoir à d'asseoir effectivement
d'asseoir leur image autour d'un grand
prix de formule 1 et de pouvoir investir
dans le coût d'achat qu'est ce que ça
soit en cas la france aujourd'hui
nantais grosjean a fait un podium la
troisième série serait director chez
nous forcément
est ce que vous allez vous représentez
aux municipales on dit un mot quand même
de rouen pour combien c'est important du
maire de rouen que vous avez été nommé
au gouvernement ce qu'on pourrait vous
représentez l'année prochaine aux
municipales ma ville c'est parce que
c'est vrai que c'est j'ai découvert
l'engagement public dire que je ne
connaissais pas en 95
en tous les cas le calendrier n'est pas
venu puisque les désignation
interviendra après après l'été et pour
l'instant je veux dire je fais ma
mission et cela ferait le plus longtemps
possible nous avez envie de redevenir
maire de rouen vraie mamie sioniste le
plus longtemps possible
nos réponses que s'achève cette émission
merci madame amis merci perrine c'est la
fin deux proches par trop très bon été à
tous puisque on se retrouve à maintenant
et à la rentrée de septembre
n'est ce pas par une grosse heure
la réalité dans le monde sait que
l'europe n'est pas la hauteur de la vie
économique ta gueule de navires de la
fille d'écologie et de la crise et de la
crise financière il s'énerve il énerve
aussi parfois quand il est hors norme
dans le paysage politique avec ses
colères sa gouaille et ses coups de
gueule y compris contre son camp alors à
quel jeu joue quand même dit que penser
de ces différentes facettes et quel
bilan tire t'il alors où il annonce sa
retraite d'europe écologie cette semaine
des avions en tout bien tout honneur un
ovni la politique des amis lyonnais
demain à 22h45 sur public sénat
une semaine politique et parlementaire
passé au crible de l'image et du
questionnement la compétitivité
maintenant c'est un problème le coût du
travail qui n'était pas un problème
n'existe pas maintenant un problème
la crise écologique et plus en plus
vivre eh bien on a besoin de changer les
choses et rapidement parlement hebdo
pour ne rien manquer pour te comprendre
c'est vendredi à 17h45
m
bonjour à tous bienvenue à banne ce
merveilleux village reculé sur tous
perchés quelque part dans le sud de
l'ardèche ici une bataille a marqué le
pays à la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale une embuscade hardiment menées
par les partisans les résistants c'était
à quelques kilomètres d'ici
dans la vallée une bataille d'envergure
qui a stoppé net la progression d'une
importante colonne allemande en route
vers le nord du pays
un homme occupe une place très
singulière dans cet épisode de
l'histoire cet homme c'est paul maës il
était maire du village
en ce mois de juillet 1944 et depuis
très peu de temps depuis moins d'un an
la toute nouvelle école de ban porte
désormais son nom
voilà je me trouve maintenant dans cette
magnifique salle de classe de la toute
nouvelle école de banal un an et demi à
peine j'ai rejoins l'un des professeurs
de l'école frédéric eu le clash bonjour
bonjour avec devant vous et bien vos
élèves aux enfants une classe de cm2 cm1
bonjour à tous alors frédéric leclerc
cette école s'appelle paul maes est ce
que c'est un nom que vous connaissiez il
ya encore quelques mois je les ai
découverts quand ils ont nommé cette
école et auparavant n'étant pas moi-même
debanne auparavant je ne connaissais pas
du tout ce personnage vous avez
peut-être regarder les plaques qui sont
sur l'école elle même est ce que vous
êtes intéressé à ce personnage de bain à
partir de ce moment là j'ai commencé à
m'intéresser à me demander d'abord
qu'est-ce qu'il avait bien pu faire et
puis d'où venait ce nom si qui n'est pas
un patronyme d'origine ardéchoise
française et donc j'ai fait quelques
recherches
alors votre école les enfants elle
s'appelle paul maz est ce que ce nom
vous le connaissez est ce que ça vous
dit quelque chose
bah je n'ai pas connu mais c'était le
maire de vannes 2-2 ce que ce que j'ai
écouté ce que j'ai entendu quand ici
alors paul maïs il était maire de bad
mais quand quand il ya eu la bataille de
ban et c'était quand ce
en 1804 quarante quatre pôles maïs était
maire en 1944 c'est à dire pendant la
guerre pendant la guerre oui la seconde
guerre mondiale et la shoah et le
village il était maire il leila chauvel
a été réaliste en est là il a combattu
également et c'est bien ce qui la fait
pas de mal je trouve
eric avec le clech merci beaucoup de
nous avoir accueillis chez vous dans
votre salle de classe sinon qu'il vous
remercie à très bientôt on va essayer
maintenant d'en savoir un peu plus sur
paul maes et sur cette fameuse bataille
de bam merci les enfants à très bientôt
au revoir
alors vous l'avez compris en cette fin
du mois de juillet 1944 paul maes le
maire de bam n'est pas tout à fait un
personnage comme les autres son action
elle intervient quelques jours à peine
après ce qu'on appelle ici la bataille
de ban autrement dit la plus grande
bataille de la résistance ici dans le
département de la neige je rejoint raul
galatto il est historien c'est l'un des
meilleurs spécialistes de cette
résistance ardéchoise
bonjour raul galatto est-ce que yoann
aujourd'hui ressemble au village tel
qu'il existait en juillet 1944 pour
l'échangé louit avec son aspect
pittoresque jugé sur sa colline de
rochers calcaires les ces ruines du
vieux château bon il ya des quelques
maisons nouvelles mais pour l'essentiel
oui c'est très typique
ban a joué un rôle tout à fait
particulier dans cette résistance
ardéchoise eh oui ban se trouve situé en
bordure d'une route à l'époque aux
routes nationales qui avait une
importance stratégique pour les armées
allemandes d'occupation dans tout le sud
de la france y compris le languedoc et
les volontaires d
forces françaises de l'intérieur
c'est-à-dire les forces armées de la
résultante ont été amenés à livrer
quelques escarmouches contre auch et
congo allemand qui circulait qui étaient
ces résistants qui ont participé à la
bataille de bain des jeunes volontaires
paysans et autres de la région de bâle
ont rejoints par des maquisards et épais
venus du gard principalement des
ouvriers mineurs dans des cévennes il ya
eu évidemment parmi les réfugiés qui ont
rejoint la résistance plusieurs l'ancien
républicains espagnols qu'on a retrouvés
dans cette compagnie aussi donc c'était
très diversifié bon au départ il y avait
quelques centaines de volontaires le 6
juin
fin juillet devait y avoir cinq ou six
mille volontaires dans le département de
l'ardèche qui était organisé en compagne
et donc encadré convenablement on avait
trouvé quand même quelques militaires
des anciens qui avait fait la guerre de
14-18 tous acquis près qu'ils avaient
quelques compétences c'est ce qui leur a
permis de livrer un combat qui
finalement était le premier combat
victorieux à en ardèche qui a précédé de
quelques jours la libération de privas
la première préfecture